[Música]
en directo América actualizamos la
información económica y por ello saludo
nuevamente en el estudio a nuestra
editora Daniela Blandón Daniela Catalán
muy bien Andrés ahí la vamos a empezar
en China allí hasta Allí se desplazó la
secretaría del tesoro de Estados Unidos
Janet yelen en medio de una creciente
tensión comercial hay muchas
expectativas sobre los resultados de
estas reuniones que tiene previstas para
realizarse desde hoy hasta el domingo
con varios funcionarios aunque no con el
presidente
un encuentro de alto nivel entre las dos
economías más grandes del mundo con una
lucha comercial de fondo que se
intensificó en los últimos días hace
apenas unos días intensificó esta
batalla tecnológica cuando impuso
restricciones a la exportación de
germanio y de galio que son dos
minerales clave para la fabricación de
Microchips y de vehículos eléctricos
entre otros esto no fue más que una
respuesta a la estrategia que viene
aplicando Estados Unidos y también sus
aliados de frenar el acceso chino a
algunos informáticos avanzados teniendo
que la alta tecnología sea utilizada por
el ejército chino Daniela pero Qué
implicaciones ha tenido la decisión de
China de restringir las ventas de
minerales clave para el sector
tecnológico bueno las empresas están con
los nervios de punta ya Volkswagen dijo
que estaba mirando Qué opciones tenía ya
que esos elementos son clave para la
fabricación de sus vehículos eléctricos
lo primero que hizo también esta
decisión fue Elevar los precios de estos
metales a medida que los fabricantes
están apresurando asegurar su suministro
pero también hizo crecer los temores de
que esas restricciones se vayan a
extender a otros minerales como las
tierras raras cuya producción está bajo
El dominio de China que supera de lejos
a Estados Unidos como lo vemos en el
gráfico que es el segundo productor de
estas tierras raras que bueno puede
sonar raro pero son un grupo de 17
elementos que se utilizan en productos
que van desde lázares y equipos
militares hasta imanes para vehículos
eléctricos tu eólicas y productos
electrónicos de consumo como los iPhone
bienvenido vamos a cambiar de tema meta
la dueña de Facebook ya lanzó la
aplicación con la que espera competirle
directamente a Twitter y antes de eso le
digo que ya la descargué hice la tarea
pero bueno ahí hay algo y es que uno
cuando pone en la app de
iPhone aparece otra aplicación que es
distinta entonces para que también
tengan cuidado Inclusive la aplicación
dice Bueno tengan cuidado Esta no es la
Instagram para que bueno pues tengan esa
precaución toca irse directamente a la
página de Instagram y allá le mando un
enlace para descargar la aplicación
bueno tienes un truco seguramente esta
otra aplicación habrá ganado un montón
de usuarios a Costa de Instagram pues
nació esta plataforma y con ella lo que
los analistas ven como una verdadera
amenaza para la red social de Iron Moscú
Twitter muy debilitada por estos días
desde que anunció que restringirá el
número de publicaciones que pueden ver
los usuarios según el ceo de meta la
matriz de Facebook y de ahora de streets
en las primeras siete horas de
aplicación logró más de 10 millones de
descargas incluyendo Kim Kardashian
también Shakira otra celebridades y
políticos fans 24 también está en esta
red social entre las características
principales está que no permite mensajes
directos pero sí publicaciones de hasta
500 caracteres fotos enlaces y videos de
hasta 5 minutos también está disponible
en más de 100 países pero en el
lanzamiento hubo ciertos inconvenientes
por ejemplo no hay acceso por parte de
los países de la Unión Europea
Aparentemente por dificultades con las
leyes de protección de datos Y tampoco
hay disponibilidad en teléfonos Android
vamos a ver qué reseñas hacen los
usuarios sobre estas porque no han
pasado todavía 24 horas desde que se
lanzó no pero se está hablando mucho de
este tema Ya hasta me obligaron a mí a
ponerlo Daniela vamos a Suiza Allí se
lleva a cabo la primera conferencia de
prensa presidida por robots Cómo fue
Pues en la agencia tecnológica Naciones
Unidas está llevando a cabo esta semana
una conferencia en la que decenas de
robots humanoides son protagonistas van
a llevar a cabo esta primera rueda de
prensa dirigida por robots lo que busca
la organización Es que la Inteligencia
artificial le ayude a cumplir sus 17
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
fijados en 2015 y que apuntan a mejorar
la vida humana y el planeta para 2030 y
que hasta el momento ocho años después
todavía se perciben como una posibilidad
bastante remota hay diferentes
características hay un robot que simula
emociones que recuerda a las personas
puede jugar inclusive al bingo con los
residentes de hogares de ancianos hay
otro que puede manejar tareas
industriales y también se están
desarrollando por ejemplo Andrés
camiones con control remoto para
entregar ayuda en zonas en donde es
difícil llegar por parte del abono
robots para todas las situaciones para
toda la ciudad de estos va a haber
robots acá presentando notas esperemos
que no esperemos que no da con Los
indicadores las bolsas mundiales caen
por tercer día consecutivo Wall Street
extiende sus caídas de ayer después de
que las minutas de la reserva Federal
mostraran que la gran mayoría de los
formuladores de políticas espera tasas
altas el día también es oscuro en las
principales plazas bursátiles europeas
con la Parisina cayendo más del 2% a
medida que crecen todas estas apuestas
por las tasas altas en el mundo y si nos
vamos para Asia El Ojo por ojo diente
por diente como diría el dicho entre
Estados Unidos y China también empezó
sobre las bolsas Hong Kong perdió un
inusual 3% en la jornada Daniela Muchas
gracias por la información económica a
descansar y nos vemos entonces en una
próxima oportunidad bueno acá nos vemos
mañana o cuando sea que esté otra vez
así será